[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the back for blood
gameplay showcase
thank you for joining us on twitch
youtube steam twitter
and backforblood.com so let's get right
to it
the show starts now
i'm golden boy and i'll be your host for
all the action today as we are minutes
away from the back for blood clothes
alpha starting up now
i'm joined in my safe house socially
distance of course with turtle rock's
very own community manager alyssa barry
top melissa it's a joy to have you here
thanks alex i'm so happy to be here in
just a few moments we're going to jump
straight into an eight-minute gameplay
demo wow not a trailer
no cg we've got 100 real gameplay
i'm all about that plus we'll hear from
the developers and game designers on the
vision behind
back for blood and later we have our
friends from smosh games
oh damien ian spencer and matt are
standing by and they're going to be
among the first to play the game
and show you just how incredibly fun
back for blood is
to play with your friends and bloody
like so buddy yeah
no you definitely don't want to forget
the blood now you probably saw though at
the game awards a special reveal shout
out to our boy jeff keely
but that was just a snack an appetizer
if you will
and we're about to give you the complete
buffet of carnage
right now here it is the first extended
look at back for blood gameplay
getting out of here is the key to my
happiness
just try not to do anything stupid
time to roll
got a lot more to do before it's over
they're buttons for punishment today
come on
stand back
nothing can stop us
don't worry get away from them much
appreciated
night night sleepyhead
not beaten yet
well hello taking point
huh who needs bullets when you have
bombs
holly what are you waiting for let's go
let's do this can we at least get
something to eat first
let's go kick some ass
ah
oh
oh this is not good
is it just me are these things getting
bigger
everybody get back
today keeps getting better and better
[Music]
we got company
gotta be something around here there you
are
[Applause]
they just keep coming
[Music]
[Applause]
wretch
i seize the
can't day until all these things are
dead don't worry i won't
oh
time to run see you guys on the other
side
we can take shelter there now you're
talking
[Applause]
[Music]
wow that was awesome now alyssa what was
that huge zombie coming out of the
ground there
well alex that was our ogre and he is at
least
20 feet tall tell me though what is the
most important takeaway that players
should know about when playing back for
blood
you've got to stick with your friends
when it comes down to it it's the
teamwork that'll get you through to the
end
now a little bit later the folks at
smosh are going to show you all at home
what it's like to be immersed in this
game and play in real time but now
let's get into the vision behind the
game and what went into creating this
world
the folks from turtle rock studios are
redefining the genre
they originally created with the iconic
left 4 dead
as pioneers within the industry turtle
rock studios has been working on a brand
new and original game
returning to their roots they plan to
deliver the definitive
next-gen co-op zombie fps with back for
blood
we've had to sit by for the past 10
years and watch other people
sort of riff on something that we
created
the community has been asking us for a
new co-op zombie shooter for a really
long time
as creators of left 4 dead we want to
take what made the zombie co-op shooter
experience so
fun and then couple that with modern day
graphics
modern day technology we're being given
an opportunity to
redefine the genre that we created so if
you're looking to spend time with your
buddies
mowing down zombies and making a big
bloody mess this is the game for you
for this game you know it wasn't enough
just to survive we really felt like we
want to do something new we want to do
something fresh we want to push the
genre the survivors
have rallied together and now we're
finding ways to push back
you were amongst a handful of survivors
that were either
resilient enough to make it through a
year of complete chaos or
you're actually immune the immunity
gives the main characters a sense of
bravado
and confidence that normal folks don't
have
you're no longer trying to find a safe
place right you're trying to create safe
places and
part of the way you do that is by going
out guns blazing and killing as many
infected as you can
from the very beginning we knew what
kind of game we wanted to make and we
identified the things that would get us
there
thrilling moment-to-moment gameplay
four-player co-op with competitive pvp
a bigger fight with much bigger enemies
and extreme replayability
before we start spending time on making
sure that the game looks good we have to
make sure that we have a fun
core gameplay experience we've been play
testing back for blood
since the third month of being on the
title
and we play test close to every day
because we have to ensure
that no matter what we do that moment to
moment is what people are expecting from
us
we think our co-op's different because
co-op isn't about just putting four
people
into a mission together co-op's about
identifying
tasks and activity and game play that
depend
on people working together if they're
not working together it's not true co-op
there is no lone wolfing in this game
you need your friends
to survive
those times when you're completely
hoarded by zombies right and
feel like you're not gonna make it and
then somehow you know you and your team
manage to pull it all together
and survive and destroy the opposition
it's an awesome feeling it's adrenaline
rush
it's one of those moments that make you
want to slap your buddies on the back
and cheer and have a beer
we wanted our characters to feel
stronger in the world and carry better
weapons
and be more organized as a unit and so
as a result we really needed the zombies
to step up their game the ridden
in our world are a lot different than
regular zombies we still have kind of
the common zombies the
traditional ones that you might see or
the fast zombies even those we added
variety
that's where the mutated zombies evolved
we have zombies that explode we have
zombies that vomit on you we have
zombies that crawl
up walls to get a higher position on you
and jump on you
our tall boy is a nine footer he's got a
big sort of lumbering slow
overhead attack that when you dodge you
feel really really good
and when you get hit by it you go flying
back with backward blood
you get the unique opportunity to
actually play as special mutations
it's one of the things the community
asks for the most as a cleaner you're
going to spend a lot of time
getting vomited on getting pounded into
gristle
the nice thing about back for blood is
that we give you the opportunity to take
the role of one of these mutated ridden
and deal some of that punishment to
other
players turtle rock believes that a good
game isn't defined by a single
playthrough but by its ability to evolve
over time
replayability is key and one of the most
important components in keeping back for
blood's gameplay feeling fresh
is its game director
we monitor players we monitor their
actions we monitor their health and then
we start
choreographing the world around them and
the idea is to guarantee that
everybody gets a roller coaster ride
so when you start a game one of the
first things that you're going to see
is the corruption cards that the game
director has played against you whether
it makes the world super dark or super
foggy and limits your visibility
or if it's throwing hordes of mutant
ridden at you right that now you gotta
face
eight of them and so then you're able to
choose
from your cards what it is that you're
gonna counter with you try different
card
combinations with your friends you can
play through the full campaign
you can replay the same mission no
experience is going to be the same
twice we're going to be constantly
making content
and watching other people make content
that we can share with each
other gamers are going to be showing us
things we didn't even know could happen
we want the game to change over time and
so we're excited to
release the game and then see what the
community attaches to
and what they get really excited about
we want to keep adding to the game
working with the community to make the
game better because that's what keeps it
thriving
we're really looking at working on this
for as many years as we possibly can
we like creating games that gamers can
dedicate themselves to and know
that i can always go back and play back
for blood and have a good time
you've got your guns you've got your
friends and you just go
and you kick some zombie ass we're gonna
make it even scarier and even more
intimidating
but you're a badass so it's not gonna be
a problem you're a zombie killing
machine
you slay zombies and that's your job and
you do it well
we're not creating a refresh we're not
creating
a redo we are listening to our community
to deliver what we do best
to advance the genre forward it's going
to be freaking awesome
the amount of effort and blood sweat
and more blood that went into this title
is remarkable
and evident when you get to play it i
saw tons of weapons from automatic
pistols
shotguns rifles how many weapons are in
this game
so what you just saw is a little taste
of what's to come
we are a shooter game but we don't shy
away from bats machetes
explosives and so much more now the card
system
looks interesting can you go into more
detail with that absolutely
so the card system is the heart of our
replayability
no two playthroughs will be the same so
then i'm correct in understanding that
even the bad guys
will get cards yes so the game director
will
increase the difficulty in very cool and
unusual ways that means tougher enemies
extra fog and even the ogre can pop up
in places you wouldn't expect
and i'm also right understanding this is
you know a fun game you can play with
your friends but is it strictly co-op or
can i run with it solo
you can play solo we have bots that will
help you out
um at the core it is a cooperative
experience so we recommend
grabbing your friends and getting out
there now it's time to watch these folks
dive
right into it please welcome from
smoshgaming damien ian spencer and matt
thank you so much golden boy and alyssa
we will not let you down unless we do in
which case we'll make it fun
so i'm going through the decks right now
these are awesome holy i feel like i'm
cheating in this game
awesome perks i know right
you know what let's go let's bogey whoa
we going
are we back for blood oh i'm a big fan
of the uzi
keep moving boys i'll guard the left if
you guys got that side
oh that noise that sound effect was so
visceral it was like a
big fan of the uzi guys not gonna lie
this
changes everything oh wow well you laid
out both
that was crazy good job all right guys
we gotta stick together don't
get don't get separated i'm coming up to
this house up here
spencer stick with us i got a propane
tank
watch out for the crew bows uh avoid the
birds
what spencer why i thought you like it
was literally just like don't touch them
gosh there's so many of them that reach
is bonkers he's got a good wingspan yeah
we did it okay we have to go into the
swamp all right let's
push aggressively let's stick together
y'all
stick together there's enemies to the
left and enemies in front oh god
league hey look we got a puker watch out
for the vomit
stop puking on me oh that's a good
vantage point right there
yeah i got him
there might be two
oh i popped him all right i never
doubted you for a second my guy
all right i want a beeline for the train
station let's let's do a 50 50 we're
like
we're moving forward aggressively but
also being a little bit
tactical about it yeah i think moving
forward is definitely
a thing to do is the thing you're never
gonna run out of ridden
oh watch out
there we go nicely done what's going on
are we running for it
i think we might have to follow your
lead let's go forward one two one go
believe in your dreams
user five where you going are we
following you yep
dude there's so many zombies behind you
okay let's do it oh my gosh
[Music]
oh god i'm surrounded oh no
oh no this could be bad this could be
bad i got you i got you i got you
there we go appreciate you we got this
we got this wow that's so many
i don't know man i think we got this
okay where do i go now um we we gotta
cross this area here
okay i hit the gravel oh look it's
filling up the gravel by the train
so now we're gonna drop over now we just
have to defend our position
oh no i'm stuck i'm stuck somebody help
okay i'm stuck
thanks for unsticking me i'll watch this
doorway i guess i'll watch this one we
got a hawker on the other side y'all
look out because they will come in
through this window behind us
oh god tall boy real tall boy long boy
in the house oh my god oh my gosh
okay there we go yep we got him
thank you spencer got your back got your
back spencer uh come to me and i'll heal
you uh
okay okay i'll take these guys out right
here please do
are we good to move yeah we're gucci
let's
go okay now where
if i were a safe room where would i be
uh dead ahead here to the right
run for the safe house if we can get
through these guys
you guys were here we did it oh sweet oh
that was the kind of teamwork and fun
experience that i was looking for
well matt's not here yet come on use it
too i'm doing stuff
come on get in matt get in get in the
safe room i got it
guys i got this yeah i should have just
closed the door on
oh my gosh wow just when we thought we
made it through just like any good
zombie movie you're like
we did it it's finally over and then all
of a sudden it's like no it's not
hi i'm a zombie and i'm here to kill you
time to open in the door
uh i'm moving towards the bridge because
that seems like the move
do we need to just run do we need to go
are we just going
oh gosh there's a lot where are we going
where are we going
i don't understand what we're doing
we're splitting the bridge what's going
on
where am i supposed to go what we're
running across the bridge
oh no i fell
that was a good move move across that
truck damien yeah that's bro
so yeah we're gonna we're gonna run oh
run yeah okay
there's like 50 million zombies running
along with me
towards you well i'm down yeah okay that
was that was all my fault
save your end
[Music]
get behind me so i can hit them with an
axe while you rez me okay
you got him you got him yeah i got him
you killed in them
here we go all right now i think you
guys go to
where we are that gather the team thing
do you see that oh i can so we got to
get to the bottom level of the ship
i'm glad this heals me but i'm taking a
lot of damage too nice yeah it's like
almost not worth it
but shotgun has a slow reload so this is
kind of the best i can do right now
all right let's run through we got to
push through whoa no i'm stuck in here
he's guarding the door just let him yeah
come now
oh yeah that was there we go that was
prosthetic
oh no oh geez this is this is this just
get to them dude just get to them just
where go where that big guy just i'm out
of stamina oh oh oh do you see the
military over there
oh nice oh that's so cool oh nice
military's here gather the team dude
awesome well i feel safe now everyone's
here oh what the
what the frick there's still zombies oh
i did not know about this element of the
game
what's up i just placed a minigun it's
like a little tower
dude that's awesome i'm gonna mount it
mini gun gopher
uh what's the goal now uh i think just
to defend this position because we can't
you have to plan explosives
too oh explosive down there is the goal
so we have to get down to the bottom of
the ship y'all
can y'all cover me yep all right three
two one let's go
spencer come with us crap there's one up
up top that needs to be done and one
down here that needs to be done probably
ahead daniel
i'm about to die where did you go i
dropped along the right side of the ship
by mistake
oh my gosh shoot i'm big dead where are
we going where you going
oh geez oh geez where
are you going there's a lot of these
guys i'm trying to go down there but the
nice dodge user for it yeah holy smokes
i don't know where anyone is anymore
it's just you and spencer dude and i'm
almost dead oh
geez can you get to me i don't know man
these these guys just keep coming i
killed my bleed out
it's not looking good y'all oh
quick somebody revive ian
did our best y'all we did our best we're
turning the main menu
well that was fun and you know what what
would this game be if there weren't room
for us to improve
well team smosh what you guys think no
this is a blast like honestly
when it comes to like four person like
kind of multiplayer experiences where
i'm both horrified and enthralled i was
a hundred percent on board that was
great
i had a really good time and it
definitely reminded me of that kind of
experience that i've been longing for
bye guys see y'all
well big thanks team smosh that was
awesome now i know after watching all
this intense gameplay everyone is
chomping at the bit
to get at the alpha but listen this
isn't your average fps
there's so much you can do and no two
playthroughs are going to be the same
here's a rundown on everything that the
closed alpha has in store to make sure
you are ready for back for blood
welcome to the world of back for blood a
thrilling cooperative first person
shooter from turtle rock studios
creators of the critically acclaimed
left for dead franchise
you are at the center of a war against
the ridden these once human hosts of
deadly parasites have turned into
terrifying creatures
bent on devouring what remains of
civilization with humanity's extinction
on the line
it's up to you and your friends to take
the fight to the enemy eradicate the
ridden and reclaim the world
with back for blood no play through runs
the same way twice
this level of variety is made possible
by the game director
that constantly adjusts to player action
creating memorable
unpredictable dramatic gameplay this
affects enemies
modifiers the environment and more
over the course of the next four days
thousands of players will be able to
play back for blood for the first time
our back for blood closed alpha test
showcases an early mission
evansburg from within the four player
cooperative campaign
in this mission you'll be able to fight
overwhelming odds
topple towering monstrosities and try to
survive
each time you play you'll face a new set
of threats as you play through the
closed alpha test
you'll also discover new items gear
and weapons to help you take your fight
against the red end further though each
time you play the game director will
change what you find and where
so make sure you run through more than
once
when back for blood launches gamers may
assume the role of eight playable
characters
known as cleaners in addition to
distinct personalities
each of these cleaners has their own
unique secondary weapon
and character perk in the back for blood
closed alpha test
players may take control of the
following cleaners walker
holly evangelo
and hoffman throughout the back for
blood closed alpha test
our battle heart and cleaners will be
required to test themselves against a
small sampling of the ribbon
you will get a taste of the threat of
these dangerous foes
the common infected stinger
wretch tall boy and the terrifying ogre
back for blood offers a new roguelike
card system
that allows players to customize their
experiences and create new challenges
when you enter a mission the game
director will play what are called
corruption cards
this will make the game more difficult
dynamic and intense for the players
for example spawning larger hordes of
enemies generating fog
or making ammo scarce players can then
play their own set of cards to suit
their play style
these cards can range from finding more
of a specific weapon
to giving your team benefits such as
faster healing or the ability to hold
more ammo
these cards are earned by completing
certain challenges and objectives
in the final game players will be able
to customize their decks to best
take on whatever threat comes their way
the combinations are endless
leaving you with a unique experience
every time
knowing all this are you prepared to
jump into back for blood's closed alpha
test we need your help to play
balance test and break our game so that
it can emerge stronger when it launches
please join us to help turtle rock
studios and warner brothers games
deliver a worthy co-op shooter the world
has been dying to play
i cannot wait to get into this game the
weapons the enemies the cleaners
that sinister game director the cards
i'm here for all of it
it looks so fun it must feel great to be
able to talk about this game finally
it's been so inspiring watching the devs
passion and creativity finally come to
life
i'm so incredibly proud of the team now
with so many unique cleaners
what sort of unique perks we can expect
for each of them
so each cleaner comes with their own set
of unique perks including and not
limited to
accuracy melee strength stamina regen
and a few more
you'll have to play to find out
don't forget you can head over to back
for blood.com or follow us
at back for blood on twitter or turtle
rock studios on discord for more info on
the alpha
updates and so much more super big
thanks to damian ian spencer and matt
over at smosh for playing around with us
and thank you alyssa for being here
today with me but the talk is done
the time is here the alpha is just about
to open so you can check out your
favorite streamers playing back for
blood now if you're watching on twitch
make sure you take full advantage check
out the custom extensions and make sure
your favorite streamer
is using them the outfit is officially
underway time for a much needed
slaycation
take care everybody
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you